MANO MARKS: Hi.
I'm Mano Marks.
Welcome to Google Maps Garage.
This is a regular show that
we're doing on Google
Developers Live.
Google Maps Garage is where
we talk about some of the
technical aspects of working
with the Google Maps API,
delve into some code, and just
sort through some common
design patterns and problems,
things that come up for
developers.
So this week, I'm going to
talk a little bit about
working with some common JSON
objects, parsing through to
get out some data, and some
gotchas that come up when
people do that, and things that
we will often see people
ask questions about
on Stack Overflow.
This is the basic map here that
I'll be working with, or
at least the basic data.
So this is the Google West
Campus, which is a part of the
main Googleplex here in Mountain
View, California.
And I just highlighted three
buildings that have large
numbers of geoengineers
in here.
We fondly refer to this
as the Geoplex.
And I'm just going to walk
through a little
how I created that.
First, though, I wanted to show
you my data source, very
simple file here.
This is the same data source I'm
going to use in every one
of the examples today.
So you see here, I just created
a file, WestCampus.js.
I created a variable West
Campus, and then it has an
array of JSON objects.
Each has a name, latitude,
and longitude.
It's a very common way for
people to create their data
and load it into Google Maps
or any other kind of
JavaScript application.
And I'm just going to say here
that often, when we talk about
common problems that happen
when building Google Maps
applications, they're actually
common JavaScript problems.
There are a few things that
are map-specific, but in
general, this is basically good
JavaScript practice, so
these things will help you out
with other things as well.
So if you'll take a look here,
one thing you'll see that I
loaded a style sheet, which I
do have created separately,
the JavaScript loader for the
Google Maps API, and then
WestCampus.js, which is the file
I was just showing you.
I created this Initialize
function here
in this script tag.
Now, generally, best practice
is to create a separate file
for all your JavaScripts.
Just for purposes of this
video, I'm going to
show it in this way.
But basically, generally, best
practice is create an HTML
file, create a CSS file, create
at least one JavaScript
file for loading in
your JavaScript.
That way, you get a separation
of presentation,
styling, and your code.
So standard stuff here.
I create the map, and center it,
and set the road type and
the zoom level.
We talked about that a lot in
the last Google Maps Garage.
And then here, what I'm doing
is I'm iterating over the
WestCampus array of objects,
and so I do a for-in loop.
So I'm just saying for x in
WestCampus, each time I loop,
it's going to create a new
building object with
WestCampus, that particular
reference to
that particular object.
Then I create a new Location
Object, GoogleMaps.long,
building.lat, and
building.lng.
And then I create a new marker
that has the location and the
building name on it and
set it onto the map.
And then you'll see here, a lot
of people use body on load
to load their initialize
function, but I prefer to use
a Google.Maps.events
addDOMListener to the window
that waits for the page to
load and then runs the
initialization.
That way, your body can continue
to load, even if the
map hasn't loaded
at that point.
So that is what you
get right here.
And you notice that I used
building.name for the title,
which means that as I hover
over a particular one--
hopefully, this will
show up on video--
I get a little tool tip there.
Not a very sophisticated one,
like using an Info window, but
it gives you enough information
without clicking
on it, just to see what
that object is.
So I'm going to switch over
now to adding in an Info
window and demonstrate at the
same time a common problem.
So this looks the same.
This is my slightly
different file.
I'm going to click on one here,
and you'll see that
whichever one I click on, it's
going to do West Campus 3 as
the Info window and load
it up using that
position as its location.
So as I scroll through here, you
can see we're doing pretty
much the same thing.
Then we're creating an Info
window for each one, and for
the content, we're setting the
content to the building name.
And you'll notice that the last
one is West Campus 3, and
that's the one it's picking up
for all the Info windows.
And then I am adding an event
listener to each marker that
says, when clicked on, open up
the Info window and set it to
the map and the marker.
Now, what were encountering here
is a common JavaScript
scoping problem.
The problem is here that yes,
you're creating a new Info
window object each time, and you
would think that when you
create the event listener,
you're actually telling it to
open up the Info window that
you're creating in that loop.
The problem is that what's
actually happening is that the
event listener is only firing
when you click on the marker.
So what happens is it's picking
up the last Info
window that was created,
and that has the last
name for its content.
So that's a problem that's
fairly easily solved, but it's
one that comes up because scope
just works a little bit
differently than how you might
expect if you're used to
working with some other
programming languages.
So here's one way to fix
the problem here.
What I've done is I've created a
separate addMarker function.
And so I loop through in the
same way that I was doing
before, and after I create
the location, I create an
addMarker, where I pass the
building name, the map, and
the location to that function.
And then in that function--
because this scope is by global
or by function here--
what we're seeing is that
that actually works.
So I create a new Info window
in that scope and that
function, and the event listener
is created there, so
it works just fine.
So now as I load that, I click
on each one, and you'll see
that I get a separate
Info window.
Now, what's interesting to note
here is this doesn't work
in a way that most Maps
applications you'll see out
there work.
Each Info window that's created
doesn't automatically
close the other Info windows.
So one solution to
that problem--
and by the way, some people do
like to have multiple Info
windows up, which is why we
allow you to do that.
You may remember back to V2, I
believe the Google Maps API,
you could only have one
Info window at a time.
So now, if we look at this
function addMarker, what
you'll see is when I click on
it, that's when I create the
Info window.
And I actually created a global
variable called Info
Window, and then I check to see
if that exists, and if it
does, then I close it.
Regardless of whether it exists
at that point, once
I've closed it, it's gone away,
and then I create a new
Info window at that
location and pass
it the map and marker.
So the only time the
Info window is
created is at event time.
So we look here, and you'll see
it's closing existing Info
windows and opening
up a new one.
So that's one good solution
to this problem.
So I just have a couple
more quick demos here.
This is creating a polyline
using the same data set.
And what you'll see here is as
I'm looping through, I create
these new Google Maps Lat Long
objects, and then I push them
into an array that I created
called Points, and then I
create a polyline, pass it the
path at points and the map,
and then it puts that
onto the map.
Now, this is a standard
JavaScript array, and you'll
see here, I've created
something that
looks exactly the same.
And what I've done instead of
creating a standard JavaScript
array is create a Google
Maps MVC array.
Now MVC, the Model View
Controller objects within
Maps, that's something that
we'll go into probably in a
later Google Maps Garage.
But the MVC array is basically
an array object that's defined
within the JavaScript API that
is much more optimized for use
with the Google Maps API.
And the reason you would want
to use that is when you are
using large numbers of points,
you will find you'll get
better performance using the
Google Maps MVC array versus
the standard JavaScript array.
So I just wanted to call that
out as a quick technique that
you can use.
And then finally today, I
actually have just a little
trick for you.
I've got Google Earth
open here.
Now often, when I'm constructing
something by
hand, I have a little bit of
trouble figuring out where
exactly things go.
So we can take a look here in
Google Earth, and I'll show
you a little bit of
what I've done.
When I was creating this, I
didn't have the latitude and
longitude of the Google
buildings.
What I did was I just went into
Google Earth and created
a bunch of placemarks.
Let's see, I have here the two
placemarks for these two
buildings, and also for
the center here.
And I do that pretty easily just
by centering Google Earth
where I want it, creating a
placemark by pushing on the
little push pin right there,
and then I can move that
around to position it exactly
where I want.
And then I click OK, and then I
just right click or control
click, and pull up Copy, create
a new text document,
and I've created a little
bit of KML here.
And so then what I can do is
I can just go into the
Coordinates Tag and pull out
the latitude and longitude
that I need for my map.
Now, the reason I am doing this
is it saves a round trip
for geocoding if I wanted to
geocode, say, the Google West
Campus one, two, and three.
One thing to note is that in
Google Earth, there the
latitude and longitude are
reversed from their positions
in Google Maps, so longitude
comes first and then latitude.
So when you copy and paste those
out, you need to just be
aware of that.
The other thing I do is Google
Earth will give you a very
high level of precision
on the coordinates.
I usually top that out at
six decimal points.
So just copy the first six after
the decimal point, and
take that and paste
that into my code.
So that's just a neat little
trick that I use when I'm
constructing my Google Maps apps
when I need a latitude
and longitude right away.
All right.
That's all we have for you in
this week's episode of Google
Maps Garage.
Please join us next time.
Thanks.